now here boris johnson has told a
meeting of energy bosses at downing
street that it'll be for the next prime
minister to make any significant
economic decisions as no new measures
were announced the executives met
together with the prime minister
chancellor and business secretary as it
emerged the energy price cap could
surpass 5 000 pounds next year
current predictions also show that the
average household could spend 571 pounds
on their energy bill next january well
let's go live to westminster our
political correspondent john craig has
the latest details from that meeting and
john no new measures announced so what
do we know about what was discussed
it was billed as a meeting to knock
heads together now there were no fewer
than
15 energy companies attending the
meeting big names that such as edf
um national grade scottish and southern
electricity scottish power centrica and
so on um they were all attending this
meeting and according to the official uh
readout uh the prime minister uh who
attended the meeting it wasn't expected
to it's due to be just the chancellor
nadim zahawi and the business secretary
kwazii quoting uh the pm according to
uh government sources said that uh
following our meeting today we'll keep
urging the electricity sector to
continue working on ways we can ease the
cost of living pressures and invest
further and faster in energy security
now
the chancellor and the energy firms
according to the government agreed to
work closely over the coming weeks to
ensure the public including vulnerable
customers are supported as unprecedented
global events drive higher um energy
costs and according to the treasury it
was noted the market is not always
functioning for consumers well if you
thought that a lot of the energy bosses
were unsympathetic to the plight of uh
consumers listen to this exchange
between our sky news colleague matt
grant and the boss of off gem
chief executive jonathan brealy
immediately after the meeting as he left
a number 11 downing street see if you uh
how sympathetic you think mr breely
sounds to the plight of customers
mr breely was it constructive meeting
nothing to say right now but of course
everyone to
the situation we're running extremely
seriously thank you what do you make of
gordon brown's uh comments calling for
nationalizing energy companies that
can't lower their bills so it's not
something i want to cover right now
that's probably a matter of politicians
rather than the regulator so are we
going to be expecting any more help for
people is it still going to be profits
over people well once again you know
that's a matter for government
the off-gem is supposed to be the
regulator and i think a lot of people
who think that uh uh the off-gem is a
fairly toothless regulator uh during
this current cost of living crisis uh
will not be impressed by the attitude of
mr breely in that exchange after the
meeting the prime minister tweeted this
i know people are worried about the
difficult winter ahead which is why
we're providing support including a 400
pound energy bill discount for all
households this morning i urged
electricity companies to continue
working on ways to help with the cost of
living but the pm did of course stress
that any extra measures will be for the
new prime minister liz trussell rishi
sunak and number 10 has insisted all
week there will not be emergency
measures before the new pm takes office
in early september one person who's got
plenty to say about all this his third
major intervention this week is gordon
brown the former prime minister who has
written another article today his time
in the guardian
saying time and tide wait for no one
neither do crisis they don't take
holidays and don't politely hang fire
certainly not to suit the convenience of
a def departing pm and the whims of two
potential successors they don't take
holidays who could he possibly referring
to be referring to there kierstarma
perhaps currently on holiday well uh mr
uh stammers allies uh claim that the
labour leader is back from holiday and
uh soon and is going to have some
engagements in edinburgh next week and
talk about labor's response to the cost
of living crisis uh next week however in
the last week or so it's certainly been
uh mr brown the former prime minister
who's been making the running on
challenging the government on the cost
of living crisis uh the pm of course uh
has attended this meeting today despite
criticism of his uh being missing in
action by opposition politicians no
mention of a windfall tax being uh
beefed up today uh the government
insists that's still on the table if the
energy companies don't start investing
more in clear and green energy uh but
liz trust does not like
windfall profits and winful taxes and so
that is pretty unlikely
indeed john thanks very much indeed